okay today I'm going to talk to you
about specialized cells now all that
specialized cells are the cells which
have particular special jobs within
animals or plants so there's six that
we're going to look at right now but
that doesn't mean there's only six
specialized cells there's just six that
we're looking at in this video the first
one is a type of plant cell called a
palisade cell now a palisade cell its
main job is for photosynthesis so
remember that is how a plant makes its
own food in the form of glucose so in
order for that to happen the most
important thing about a palisade cell is
that it contains these little organelles
called chloroplasts so in a palisade
cell we'll see lots and lots of
chloroplasts because they're found in
the leaf and this is the site of
photosynthesis where the plant will make
its food okay specialized cell number
two is a root hair cell now there's a
clue in the name of where we find this
it's found in the root of a plant now
this one is a bit different from our
palisade cell because it's in the root
it has a different job it's job is to
absorb water and minerals so that's its
particular job now if we have a quick
look at the structure of the root hair
cell we'll see it's a bit different
because it does not contain any
chloroplasts this is because the roots
are underneath the ground so there's
going to be no sunlight therefore no
photosynthesis now the reason why we
have this protrusion from the end right
here is to give it a large surface area
so these the two plant cells we're
looking at this got a large plot large
surface area to absorb as much water and
minerals as possible okay next up we
have our ciliated cell now this is a
type of animal cell for example it's
found in humans so our ciliated cell has
got loads of these little hairs which
are called cilia that's why this is
called a ciliated cell now what happens
is these little hairs they can move and
that's kind of like little brushes so we
can find them in a couple of different
places if they're found in the trachea
so that's like the windpipe or Airways
throughout the human body they remove
dust and bacteria so these little cilia
they move in order to clear the airways
we could also actually find them in the
of adults to move egg cells along so
that's an example of an animal cell
notice how it doesn't have a cell wall
this is a specialized cell because as a
special particular job next up we have
red blood cells so red blood cells
another type of animal cell now they
have this shape which is called a
biconcave disc shape now actually red
blood cells are kind of strange because
they have no nucleus the reason why they
have this biconcave disc shape and no
nucleus is to give it a large surface
area because the whole job of a red
blood cell is to carry oxygen around the
body so if we've got a large surface
area it just means it can carry more
oxygen around the body with oxygen binds
to this particular thing within the
within the red blood cell called
hemoglobin so hemoglobin is just
something within the red blood cell that
the oxygen combines to again it's a
specialized cell because as a special
particular job of carrying oxygen okay
the next two we're going to look at our
types of cells called gametes that just
means sex cells so these are the two the
two types of cell involved in
fertilization so first of all we have
this one here which is a sperm cell okay
sperm cell now we have a few different
features the most striking and obvious
feature is the fact it has a tail this
allows the
cell to move it also has this middle
section that is packed with these
organelles called mitochondria these
mitochondria provide the sperm with lot
sperm cell with lots of energy so it can
swim it also has something called an
acrosome now what an acrosome is is it's
a little kind of compartment in the head
of the sperm that releases enzymes that
allows it to break through the membrane
of the egg cell that we'll be looking at
in a minute so the whole job of this one
is fertilization final thing to say
about it is it has a nucleus but the
nucleus is said to be haploid that just
means it has half the number of
chromosomes compared with a normal
animal cell that's just so when it
combines with the egg cell we get the
full diploid number so guess what the
last one we're looking at its another
gamete the other gamete it's called an
egg cell so sperm cell and produced in
the testes by men egg cells produced in
the ovaries by women so what we have is
the egg cell looks like this now the
exhales especially adapted because in
the cytoplasm there are lots of
nutrients because these as the as the
embryo starts to develop upon
fertilization nutrients provide the
embryo of what it needs in order to grow
in the Vallon now also we have a nucleus
and just like the sperm cell it is
haploid as well so half the number of
chromosomes because when the sperm cell
and the egg cell combined
that's called fertilization we have the
DNA joining the chromosomes joining they
go from the half amount of chromosomes
to the full amount so haploid two
diploid so again our egg cell is
involved in fertilization just one final
thing that these aren't joint drawn to
scale
in reality sperm cells are much much
smaller than egg cells so here's where
they release that their enzymes from the
acrosome
in order to get into the egg cell in
order for their nuclei to combine that's
fertilization soon as the sperm has got
in the membrane of the egg cell this is
another way it's specialized
the membrane of the egg egg cell changes
so no other sperm can get in
so just to recap these are specialized
cells specialized cell just means a cell
with a particular job a specialized job
these two are the two types or two of
the types of plant cell we need to know
about these are two types of an animal
cell these are also animal cells but
their gametes which means sex cell and
these are the different features that
allow them to do their jobs thank you